What foods, etc. should one avoid if you are prone to kidney stones?
So if you're prone to kidney stones, you could have a problem with oxalates. Most kidney stones are oxalate based.
So stay away from foods that have high oxalates with. So you could Google
foods with high oxalates. You're gonna see rhubarb. You're gonna see
spinach, you know, I don't know everything else, but it would be high oxalate foods.
That would be really the thing to stay away from. We have a product from
professional health products that's called oxalate scavenger.
That might be something to think about adding as well. That could grab on to oxalates in your gut to help you
excrete them. People that are prone to kidney stones, back in the day we used to call people
quote unquote, stone formers. People that are stone formers tend to absorb a lot of oxalates,
whereas most people will excrete oxalates in their gut. But if you absorb a lot of oxalates,
you could be prone to kidney stones, gallstones, bladder stones. You could be prone to
tendonitis with laid out of calcium. So calcific tendonitis, calcific spur formation.
We'd see that a lot when you take an x-ray of somebody's ankle or foot and have these spurs on
their tendons. Those are people that would be considered used to be the old term was called bone
formers or stone formers. Those are people that absorb a lot of oxalates. There can be reasons why
a person absorbs a lot of oxalates genetically. They're the oxalate genes. There can be just
got issues why somebody absorbs a lot of oxalates. But there is a product from PHP called oxalates
scavenger. And that could help grab on to oxalates and get rid of them when you're gut.